the Joe Rogan experience there's no way
you're gonna get through this life
without some mental struggle there's no
way he'll wait it's not possible because
if you just sit around and do nothing
you'll be filled with a it can't do that
just because of the world address so
much [ __ ] there's too much [ __ ] going on
everybody's got struggles there's no way
around it no way around yeah and a
person don't have to struggle dumb
[ __ ] probably that close to
being suicidal mm-hmm you don't say
people have died it are the ones that go
first I think a strong community is
important you know I having a lot of
people around you that you love you know
family friends like that's that's
important to people that you could talk
to like fit well you feel loved I think
one of the real problems of people that
that this just it doesn't feel fixable
is when they feel alone it feels like
them like them by themselves yeah yeah
yeah they don't feel like they're there
in a like a group they don't feel like
they're in a community don't they just
feel like nobody gives a [ __ ] about them
whether they live or die
and that's one of the saddest feelings I
think you could have how could you make
somebody feel like that's as awful to
make something but then those same
people probably have don't have that one
person didn't he confide in that one
person there's not gonna [ __ ] him
the one person doesn't want anything
right yeah if you don't have anyone in
your life you don't have anybody that's
telling you the truth or lying you know
and there's a lot of people out there
that are real lonely that only exist on
the Internet
you know an Internet is the the Internet
is the most fabricated lonely place in
the world and it's so it's it's
interesting because it's like like
especially what we do is like you feel
like you need it but after a while they
should have just so [ __ ] overwhelming
yeah and it's so easy for a person to
carve out the perfect life people to
tell you like oh my god I thought you
was having so much fun on vacation this
isn't it you know how [ __ ] many takes
it takes to get that perfect picture
just show everybody that your life is
the [ __ ] bomb yeah it's just not it's
not an accurate representative of
anybody's life and it's everywhere and
that's where everybody wants to show
their less I said did you tell average
chick right I won't say on the street
but it's the average woman if you tell
them that I want to take you on a
vacation
anywhere in the world you want to go but
you can't bring a phone you know what
have them uh folks say let me think
about that because nobody wants to have
a memory and shared memory just from the
memory they have right it's like they
wanted to get validate they want people
to get the thumbs up and everything
[Applause]